even before today's session started it
was visibly very clear what issue would
dominate
government and opposition whips were
handing out blue and yellow ribbons the
colours of the ukrainian flag banned
when the country was part of the soviet
union some mps opted for lapel pins with
both the uk and ukrainian flags others
made their support clear with their
clothes
and midday the speaker said this
i want to welcome to our gallery the
ukraine ambassador
[Applause]
you're right
applause is rare in the commons standing
ovations even more so this lasted almost
a minute
ambassador vadim prusteiko stood up in
the gallery put his right hand to his
chest and bowed some mps were on the
verge of tears
we generally do not allow applause in
this chamber
but on this occasion the house quite
rightly
wants to demonstrate over respect and
support for your country and its people
in the most difficult of times
kyostama's core argument today was that
the government needs to go further
faster on sanctions
they dip their hands in the blood of
putin's war for too long britain has
been a safe haven for stolen money and
now is the time to sanction every
oligarch and crack open every shell
company so we can prove putin wrong
now the labour leaders team while
broadly supportive of the pm argue that
just like in afghanistan the government
never plans properly and only acts in
moments of crisis now skyne's analysis
of the labour leader's language
underlines his focus on the speed of the
government response and the fact his
party will support tougher measures due
in the economic crime bill on monday
boris johnson robustly defended his
actions arguing the uk has moved quicker
than most other western powers and he
made this announcement
what we will publish in addition uh mr
speaker is a full list of all those
associated with the putin regime the
prime minister also made his views on
potential war crimes crystal clear
uh what we have seen already uh from
vladimir putin's regime in the use of
the munitions that they have already
been uh they've been dropping on as on
innocent civilians mr speaker in my view
already fully qualifies as as a war
crime
in our analysis of boris johnson's
language the word he used most as you
can see here were putin and regime
followed by the word already because of
course the pm spent much of today laying
out the steps taken by his government
thus far
elsewhere one mp started speaking in
ukrainian dublin
and now they use the legal protection of
parliamentary privilege to name names of
alleged putin allies aurasmanov sechin
peskov abramovic roald dugan and a third
attacked the pm for donations to the
tory party from rich russians will the
prime minister instruct the conservative
party to give to ukrainian humanitarian
causes the two million pounds they've
accepted from lubov to new kin mr
johnson was keen to make this important
point this is not about the russian
people mr speaker this is about the
putin regime
as long as the war in ukraine continues
to make headlines and lead news
bulletins expect future sessions of pmqs
to feature questions on tougher
sanctions a more generous refugee policy
and increased humanitarian support